the illegal sex drug ghb
is killing young people who take it for
fun
and it's become a deadly weapon in date
rape
but officially ghb is only a class c
drug
no more harmful than a sleeping pill
before the coved lockdown we asked
regulars at the eagle
how aware they were of the dangers a
very small dosage of that
can lead you to being in a very serious
condition
it's very very scary police say that
since the lockdown
dangerous misuse of the drug may even
have increased
some ghb users are live streaming
drug-fueled sex sessions online
and encouraging many others to join in
on zoom
calls paddy blah died
two years ago from a fatal overdose of
ghb
he used such so-called chem sex drugs on
the gay party scene
paddy's parents don't know if someone
gave him ghb that night
or he chose it or if he even knew what
he was taking
it's very dangerous killing people
people are getting abused raped on it
and people aren't educated to know
if they just take a tiny tiny little bit
extra
it can cause them to die paddy was a
triplet
his parents believe the drug that killed
him should be reclassified from c
to a like heroin cocaine and ecstasy
if we say this is a class c the message
is
it's safe it's not safe neither the
hospitals the coroners
or the home office seem to have a handle
on it in manchester the uk's most
prolific
rapist reynard sinaga spiked drinks with
ghb
to subdue his victims the case prompted
a home office review of the drug's low
classification
so i don't even know if it is the same
thing he were talking about but
in east london gay serial killer stephen
port drugged his victims with ghb
four of them died from an overdose
now sky news can reveal that across the
uk in the past three years
ghb has been linked to many more crimes
including rape and attempted murder
police recorded 31 cases in 2017
37 cases in 2018
and 44 cases last year but the figures
are likely to be much higher
because more than half the police forces
we ask
refuse to give us their ghb statistics
scotland yard said our request for the
information was
vexatious it meant it thought we were
being
unreasonable police insist they
are aware of the danger of ghb
you can take three milliliters and you
might have the best section experience
you've ever had
people take five milliliters it can lead
to fatal overdose
the true dangers of ghb may be
underestimated
because the drug is not part of routine
toxicology testing
and it disappears from a body rapidly
it's now being used there's not only a
recreational drug in some of the larger
groups of youth
very young people are getting into it
you can order it online and get it
delivered the next day and it's becoming
a party drug in that young sect and this
is where there are starting to see some
sad deaths because of the instability of
that
ideas drug the home office said the home
secretary was deeply concerned at the
use of drugs such as ghb
in crime she's urged her advisors
to speed up a study to see if controls
are tough enough
martin brunt sky news